today we're going to talk about the
Forgotten Indian player mainly forgotten
due to Vishy Anand being the best Indian
player since before your
great-grandfather was born obviously
this year on five-time world champion
potala Hari Krishna Hari Krishna is also
a very strong player 2700 feet a for
much of his career but okay career sort
of overshadowed by a non-hairy Chris has
visited Michigan my home state before
giving a simultaneous exhibition and I
saw Hari Krishna when I was in China at
the World Team Championship in 2011 and
not doesn't play generally for the
Indian teams so Hari Krishna's often
board one or board two so I want to look
at some of his end games now one of the
things I noticed in looking at his
endings is a position like this he often
has obviously colored bishops often with
rooks and he wins these end games that
looks drawn that's one of my pet peeves
a lot of books and people will say when
it's obviously colored bishops it tends
to be a draw but I found in chess it
almost never tends to be a draw unless
the players in the top ten in the world
that you can win almost any position
where you have the advantage now
obviously black has an advantage here
because he has an extra pawn though that
pawn is pretty well blockaded okay now
this is a funny game because it goes
with something else that I like to teach
a lot of times when grandmasters are
playing non grandmasters they go too far
trying to win they'll do anything to win
no draws so if the game is looking like
a draw they might go crazy and sometimes
lose okay usually win spectacularly but
and this is just such an instance here
actually black doesn't have much of an
advantage because his pass D pawn can't
really move and after the move rook C to
check if the black King
moves backwards black doesn't really
have any advantage because there's just
no way he could advance his deep on so
here he made a move that only Julian
would have make it a one minute game
Bishop c4 cept he played it in a
tournament game he wasn't kidding
and he's trying to trade advantages
he's has an opposite collar Bishop
ending but he's trying to sacrifice his
bishop and get a big pawn majority on
the Queen side and hope that he can win
this position now if two supercomputers
are playing Bishop c4 will not be played
and computers obviously prefer white now
because why it's going to be a piece
ahead but okay both sides have winning
chances and how are you Christian feels
he can outplay his opponent in this new
complicated situation now his opponent
was up to the task and actually played
very strongly here play the move Bishop
e7 check the King has to go to b5
otherwise we're not protecting the
bishop on c4 and we will get our extra
pawns and he played a four check which
is the best move so probably Hari
Krishna overlooked this move when he
played Bishop c4 because he was probably
hoping you know for something like this
okay and black has a lot of pawns and
can try to win even though he's probably
worse now here he certainly worse after
a four check if he moves his King it'll
just be a piece down for almost nothing
and that's what happened the problem
with taking on passant is you know his
pawns aren't very good and there's no
there's no dangerous past pawns
okay so iron Chris should play King a6
and now if he just takes back he'll you
know has to Queen his be pawn luckily
the be pawns hard to stop with the rook
on f1 so the game is still complicated
and now white sort of went astray in
this position and let back in black into
the game probably with an equal position
the obvious move rook takes c4
gives black chances with either b3 and
the pawn is dangerous or rook a1 and
there's no defense to the a4 pawn again
not so easy for blacks to get any
winning chances but he's trying yeah
rook in fact that's actually what
happened
yeah that's C I missed that and his
opponent missed it even though I already
saw the game you see what happens when
you look at 20:30 games you start to
fall asleep so yeah in fact I'm guessing
when this started Hari Krishna realized
unlike me the after Bishop e7 check
there is this this skewer and that's why
he has chances okay and he could play
the skewer here but I have rook to eat
oh so ok so he played King to d4 and
nine times out of ten I would be like
yay King to d4 because I always wanted
my king up in the endgame here
the engine recommends King to e2 which
stops black from playing rook e1 it
gains a temple on the rook and the c4
pawn is still attacked so King u2 is the
computer move he played King to g4 rook
e1 attacking the bishop and okay here
white lost his nerve white should keep
his bishop and the engine says it's a
draw but it'd rather have white but he
played rook takes e4 which is just
begging for a draw he's hoping he can
draw this rook and pawn ending but he
can't so it would be better not to give
the bishop away just for a pawn like I'm
against it so yeah now obviously blacks
the only one playing for the win
so Hari Krishna's gamble paid off the
computers preferred white and now black
is virtually winning Rick c6 check King
a7 again King b7 sort of the obvious
move the guy checks oh you attack his
rook but this position we want to Queen
our pawn
always a good idea and one of the ways
we're going to Queen our pawn is by
putting the rook on b7 and putting our
look behind the pass pawn
if you learn nothing else this lecture
and you want you should put your rooks
behind pass pawns that is the pawn moves
forward your rook becomes more active
protects the pawn while it's moving so
King a7 makes a lot of sense because
often black wants to play rook to b7
King C for stopping the pawn from moving
rook check forcing the King to make a
decision the King moves up I can push my
beep on the King was back I can check
and take on g3 so I moved up b3 King
takes and now very nice move rook to e7
I'm guessing white overlooked this move
ok the idea is I want to play rook to b7
and Queen my pawn and if you play route
to b6 I'll still play rook to b7 so now
my B pawn is about to Queen and it's
very hard to stop now here white played
a really nice trick and black sort of
fell for it but he's still winning
but it was sort of nice stop the pawn
this way and now after route b7 we have
a word you don't hear very often at rook
and pawn endings zips long white can't
move if white loses rook black will
Queen and white has no other moves and
so here white played for a trick and you
may have noticed maybe you didn't Julian
obviously notice he's about to say it
right unfortunately that doesn't work
for two reasons and how he Christian
shows the worst reason but good enough
right so white played for stalemate okay
and White's King can't move so if he can
sacrifice his rook he just needs to make
sure these pawns can move but they can
move so he got rid of them g4 f5 now the
quicker way to win according to the
engine is to Queen our pawn okay but how
are you Christian knew that he was going
to win anyway after takes rib takes
beats who was played if you take the
rook it stalemated but he didn't take
the rook so
tried and he failed miserably the lesson
is never try never try so black played
g3 and he's like I'm going to Queen my
pawns and now white played a very funny
move showing he has a sense of humor
unlike Julian no sense of humor Hugh
rook F 2 then I play rugby 5 check
double X clan you hate when that happens
but I like our variation it's like we're
the beginner of the beginners okay so
Rick f2 if I take it it's still me
that's not good and if I play rugby 5
check then I do that somehow so instead
he played a much funnier move that
you'll like rook b6 yeah how do you like
that okay that's what you would play so
now if rook takes rook it still made
although if I don't play rook takes rook
I get to Queens it's all together
alright so you played Rick g7 instill
meeting and White had his laughs and he
resigned there's no more stalemate but
you have to remember that when you're
winning an endgame and you know you're
going to win he might not win there
could be a sail man you were the crazy
comment yeah you got me on that yeah and
that was creation Wi-Fi you're going to
say hi and after the game all the people
who are watching yelled Hari Krishna
several times alright yeah 5050 also you
could win after King a hey yeah so Rick
check rook takes a stalemate
kingi loses but King takes is hard to me
yeah you should give it a try yeah yeah
5050 that's right
alright now actually I have two games
with Arenberg which is very strange now
you're not having deja vu okay you're
not having a flashback although maybe
you are this is still a rook and office
of Bishop ending but it's against
somebody else now here white has two
legal moves one of them hangs matin one
so he didn't play that one
okay then there would be a very short
lecture okay he played King a to now if
you play King C to which is what you
were going to play at home Rick see one
mate is good for black because the
game's over
okay so King a two now most of you in
the audience would agree to a draw here
four pawns each rook and opposite color
bishops how could anybody win Black has
a very large advantage of this position
for one reason what reason is that
yes pass pawn the e-file if you want to
win end games I recommend getting a
queen you're probably not going to
actually could check me if he plays king
c2 I stand corrected it's hard to check
me with just two rook or just a bishop
or even with both but with a queen now
you're looking good it's about time you
look good look at you come on terrible
okay I'm not talking to you guys talking
to them at home okay they know who I'm
talking to
okay so not only does black have a
passed pawn black would like to have a
second pass pawn so he played Bishop to
d4 getting out of the way of his past
pawn now he can push it this ship f7 the
point of this ship f7 is that white
wants to play Bishop e8 and get to
passed pawns and black was like to pass
pawns I agree and so what moves a black
play so everybody could have to pass
pawns and he won king c5 I showed you
now rook F lung was correct but you play
king c5 and then rook f1 and everybody
was happy now it's looking less draw
because we both have to pass pawns
however now the big difference is of the
number of passed pawns what is the big
difference the thing that I talk about
often in the endgame every end game
lecture I say the same thing I push the
repeat button yeah black has a good King
it's very active it will help our pawns
forward White's King is good at getting
checkmated okay white played Bishop c2
which is a terrible move and actually my
is me a beginner breakdown class with
Mike comer looked a little different
today I think he added a few pounds over
the week Rick see to check or be for
check we're better moves either kicking
the black king away or pushing our past
ones bishop steeds who reminds me
beginner breakdown because it attacks
upon okay but that's a really bad score
for the bishop rookie five and now
blacks good you were just like him
beginner breakdown push those pass pawn
be four check King C - King C - King see
you later and now the bishop on c2 is
really badly placed the black king is
walking in rook to the seventh King to
the sixth see I told you King seats who
you thought I would miss punk
you're right but I was still right okay
now the bishops hanging rook there
that's what you know you're doing a good
job when you move your rook back and
forth that's when you know things have
gone well well the problem is if you
play rook c7 Shaq you're helping black
even more King - D - it's very hard to
stop the e pawn from queening and f5 and
this is just too easy now Bishop to g1
Bishop to e3 Bishop g2 attacking the
bishop
what's that call interference yeah King
b1 always play King b1 III with the idea
of f4 f3 came to d3 and again this
reminds me of the game that I show off
in an endgame class is between Sabina
Foy's or and I read as ENIAC although I
should have said Jenny octopus or where
both Kings were on the back rank once I
moved their King up the other side never
moved your king so she lost this is very
similar materials equal but blacks King
is a lot better than whites e - and for
some reason why it's not resigning very
strange okay and why you resigned so
yeah that's what you know things aren't
going on when you play rook g7 work to
g2 so in that game my past pawns were
better than yours they were further
advanced my King was further advanced
the obviously colored bishops actually
helped because the bishop on d2 was
separating the
defense of the rook and the bishop and
black white just couldn't defend so that
was a nice game from Hari Krishna
I guess Arenberg is his favorite
opponent because he beat him again later
in the lecture
wasn't it a Nierenberg play here at the
u.s. championship now he plays the
German player Christopher Lutz
now I've actually seen this end game
before before any of you were born
Alex Fishbein had it I don't know if you
had the better side of the or the worse
side I remember how he did either I knew
was in New York open and it was 30 years
ago now this should be a draw but
sometimes when you have only one or two
legal moves you pick the wrong one there
reminds me of a funny story
if only bill Thompson was here because
it's a bridge story I was playing bridge
and I had two cards in my hand
I played the wrong one so if I put the
other one we've been great but I didn't
play the right one so I would have done
better if I had not even known which
card was which but after I thought about
it that didn't help okay
well here black played Bishop e5 check
White has very few legal moves okay two
of them lose and one of them draws okay
I could give a hint that's too easy for
everybody when I say everybody I mean
Alex Marlar
but God accounts key would easily find
the drawing move giving the answer away
okay although you also give you what you
and unfortunately why didn't find it and
he lost in my opinion which Alex fish
mine will either totally agree with or
totally disagree with because he's very
opinionated about this he's actually
studied rooking two pieces against rook
in one piece who would studied that but
he has so I'm going to ask him he
studied this Bishop at night against
Bishop the ship at night against Knight
I'm pretty sure this is a draw okay and
if you trade any pieces off it's a draw
trade the bishops try bishop for the
night anyway it wasn't a drive for what
he did because he sort of helped his
opponent out by doing the Stein it's
Ian's move my King towards your pieces
so he made the illegal move King g3
kingi 3 is not illegal because in chess
you are in check when one or two pieces
are checking you here it's three that's
not in the rules now that's actually was
an old rule they changed it yeah King g3
used to be legal as far as the rules
were concerned then they got some better
word Smith's and they improve the rule
okay
so we'll call it a random student Alex
Marlar what should white do you sit in
the back he get called on this is like
you're still in school
King x1 very calm CSKA view King h1 is
the drawing move or at least white
doesn't lose right away moving away from
blacks pieces okay and also when I play
King h1 my rook can block all kinds of
stuff on the second rank he played King
g2 and now black played a fabulous move
I mean I'm very impressed and I'm not
easily impressed oh wow there's a blue
car wow yeah did you see that okay I
mean I direct Simpsons Club okay all
right so what's the winning move here
for black it lets him control squares
attack the White King and sort of inch
closer bishop g3 very good it's like
you're the highest rated player in the
room CR you see we've got Mario yeah you
are the highest no I think I am Joe
who's higher you were Alex Lopez
well you're pointing to each other Wow
okay we didn't say that
we didn't you beat an IM your last
tournament okay so you it's better a
blitz chess yeah okay it's better he's
been on the Internet yeah he'll beat you
arm wrestling I'm not sure that stress
want to see what you would say all right
so Bishop G 3 very good now we can play
Knight f4 with check which would not be
check if the King was on h1 okay so Rick
d1 stopping all kinds of back rank
checkmates like rook e1 is no longer
mate which it would have been rubbed to
g2 that's a lot of pieces attack
okay so that's not good and now black
can set up all kinds of meeting nets and
why can't really do anything Bishop g4
tagging the rock check check and now the
PS the resistance if you can attack with
three pieces you should attack with four
pieces no I mean you know what I mean at
home how do we get an extra piece of the
attack are we playing bug house
maybe then we take a piece from off the
board you King g5 ah and the bishop is
protecting H 3 and E 2 and if I can play
9h three check or 92 check then Rick H 2
is going to be made and the bishop on g4
stopping them both but I just attacked
the bishop on g4 don't you hate when
that happens
ok so he played I can't figure out what
he played he didn't play anything he
resigned
let's move the bishop somewhere that's
somewhere let check checkmate okay so
King g5 was nice because he got four
pieces attacking so I like the pawn
Westend games computers are really good
upon this endings so instead of
wondering whether the starting position
was a win I could have gone to the
internet and found out in seconds I
don't have that kind of time I'm busy
okay he submitted that email I got
you're busy yeah right yeah I was
sleeping while reading that email that's
how busy I was okay so here the bishop
can't stop Knight age three and night e
2 because the King is attacking the
bishop so white resigned I would play
for some still and I just don't see a
stalemate
rook g5 what does not tell me I could
take either piece and there's no sale
man I'm not even sure which piece I
should take yeah well you do what are
you doing you made every legal move wind
what are you oh yeah that's right
another legal move wins yeah I think so
yeah not a good defense okay so white
resigned even a better defense
yeah actually that's the best move and
it says rook G to check then rook H to
check then King digs Bishop yeah
although you could also take and mate
with bishop at night it's really easy
here because the King yeah okay
anyway resins etc that's the store that
I went to once okay now I want to ask
you a question so I'll show you get with
Peter ax how do you actually said ox ox
apply with an H right come on who speaks
like check in here Hungarian Hungarian
right you know you're the worst person
who ever lived
man you give the guy a day off and you
start talking crazy
all right now I really like this ending
because none of you know who's better
here and you're like wait a minute which
side is Hari Krishna okay he's better
yeah okay so now this is this is just
awesome well black is better for several
reasons okay Black's down the exchange
which makes him better yeah you agree
with that two bishops past H pawn bishop
on d3 fantastic blacks King is safer
black has a pasty pawn and this Bishop
very suspicious the bishop was on e5
okay that maybe whites better but this
Shibani three terrible passive so black
why can't really do anything and this is
my favorite move of the game I didn't
even see the game but I'm pretty
confident okay also it might be White's
move because I do that a lot
anyway if you were black what should you
play here and these are the kinds of
moves that I like that your opponent
won't see okay
unless he's French and you you're like
you know 66 and 2/3 right you yeah well
that might be White's move there we go
okay so none of a white black plays
Queen CA exactly right and Queen d7 is
also good but Queen C it's even further
right I would play Queen b9 if possible
fact that's probably even better
yeah Queen b9 is even better okay
and the
who've obviously is Queen 8n right okay
so now we're going to I like retreating
and I like with my Queens over here
checkmating you I like that too okay so
the queen is repositioning itself or as
yessir Surma would say don't you guys
all know this Irwin lectures he doesn't
say that calls it a billiard shot yeah
yeah he's hitting it off the cushion
yeah yeah though it has to stop
he's real good touch okay so queen c8
so now if you thought you were desperate
and you're right white gets real
desperate here okay now white goes crazy
because blacks going to infiltrate on
the Queen side I really like Queen CA so
why he played f5 with brilliant counter
play after Queen b7 Bishop takes h6
which Julie we played a one-minute game
all day he would take white here any day
of the week because vision make six yeah
now White's crashing through on the
Kings side and almost has a threat
almost okay but okay so why tried but ok
blacks first I really like the
repositioning of the Queen it reminds me
of your favorite game then Feingold Yuri
balakov which move did I play that game
that was interesting you you really
don't know yeah but way before that how
did I reposition my queen yes from yes
you know
yeah Queen do you want and it was Queen
HHR yeah but yeah Queen but this Queen
see it's a b7 reminds you that when I
was a little kid I was little okay yeah
I can back that up as long as I want to
prove it I saw a game between tal and by
vidiq and then tall played Queen
somewhere back to G once revolution is
queen I was like that's awesome
I'm only rated 900 but I'm going to do
that someday okay and I did Queen B to
check now King e1 is risky and so is
King d1 do to checkmate so he ran his
King up the board and then he made the
only legal move and now what happened
Queen d2 now if you move your king then
Queen takes bishop is pretty good and if
you play queen III then what is black do
Queen III blocking all checks the answer
is it doesn't matter all moves win Queen
takes Queen wins Queen h2 wins and as
Roman ginger hush feely would say he
wouldn't say that I mean he might say
that he would say I am looking but I
cannot find a move that doesn't win okay
and this position there was an axe to
grind and he resigned so white resigned
due to losing his Bishop on h6 he tried
to give this ship on h6 away but before
black could take it he resigned so he
was ahead material hurray for him but
okay if you if you block with a queen
for example I'd probably play queen h2
but now I got the two bishops so now I
would win I mean I would okay now I want
it like correct some of the you know
some of the confusion that we have here
this is how I criticize chenko but not
these Savchenko so I want to like allay
your fears here and these Savchenko is
your sort of Russian you let's first see
what yeah yeah there we go yeah that's
pretty good actually you got there
that's good made-up accent okay so Boris
Savchenko but this is VSU Slovak you
know would they find this guy on the
side of the road come on okay so now
this guy is you know Rufus yeah yeah
that's what I said well yeah but
re-grease is 2700 you know okay
so White's up the exchange that he's in
trouble but don't worry he gives it back
soon okay now here's what most of you do
and that's why you're not Hari Krishna
okay you're some guy sitting in the
kingside diner
especially you I was thinking to you
okay you guys are like oh I'm up a rook
for a bishop he start dusting yourself
off right doing this
the greatest and eventually I'll win and
Hari Krishna's like I have a better idea
I'm gonna check with my opponent now
okay and then the game's over okay not
like all about the exchange I'll win
eventually okay so our Ukraina says he I
have three puns in front of my king my
opponent has two pawns my coat upon his
King is a bit Airy okay we have to
punish our opponent so white played the
obvious move Queen d5 rips a g6 hanging
a rook right he played f5 nobody saw
Brooke f7 okay f5 rawr okay attack also
we have a discovered attack just in case
okay now black wasn't worried at all he
just took the pawn and he's like you
can't take my bishop because I'll take
your rook but he forgot he was up the
exchange and why can sacrifice the
exchange it's great okay it takes rook
g3 check okay now ya whites whites a
king is a lot safer than blacks all
right now King h8 is risky because of
Queen d8 check very it's all risky yeah
alright and I think you played King f8
yeah and rook g7 what do we do it's the
same as the last move Queen d8 I like
this ending is it's a checkmating attack
in the endgame now Queen and work
endings are notoriously famous
especially the most famous one Queen and
rook against Queen and rook decided the
fate of the World Championship now
slightly before your time probably
oh you're so close the correct answer
obviously was Lasker and Schleck sure
okay taking a winning Queen rook ending
and losing it man it's tough but fair
here the end of the match - okay you
guys can correct me on YouTube okay
although you're wrong this time
alright now king f7 and we got a little
skewer action for you going on there and
black resigns even though that wasn't
the game I resigned for him okay so he
played King f8 now there's a famous
saying possibly by Lasker and if I'm
wrong could be the other last league I
got two chances okay
and he said unless it was somebody else
Alex Muller will correct me if you see a
good move look for a better one you
terrible well that's correct and now in
this position everybody would play the
incorrect to move correct and that's
incorrect
that's not the right move okay now Rick
g8 Shaq wins the Queen for a ruck and
Hari Krishna's like whoa slow down
let's win war that's illegal but you're
right
because you met Queen d6 so you're right
Queen d6 is even stronger
yeah do say e six oh then you're even
more right then you're even more right
that's correct yeah now if black plays
the obvious move Ricky seven okay then
we check he makes a move that's legal
and we check and now we have a really
cool meetin - I'll wait white mates in
two moves it's recommended because then
you win listen end game lecture we'll
play it for checkmate over here Martin
made into very hard
no it's White's move oh yeah that's even
harder black has to do it yeah black
gets checkmated anyone anyone made into
I don't see your hand Julian Martin
again that's his name now he'll make a
move for Wyatt rook takes 8 7 would win
but I want meat and two I don't want no
meat and three made for matin 27 I don't
want to 27 Yankees I want the 84 Tigers
you the magician row g6 unfortunately is
correct
very good rook g6 check and me notice
King here is illegal because I've rigged
g6 track ok so black didn't do that
because black didn't want to get
checkmated now as Julian pointed out
rook g8 Shaq would win the Queen for a
ruck but in the game he played this and
he did the same thing except now the D
pawn is gone much more accurate ok
showed you that computer agrees to now
all your pawns are hanging because now I
got Queen e6 Queen e5 check and I take
all the pawns I do this yeah yeah and
this is a good trick to know the king is
defending the Queen so you remove the
defender and decoy and several other
words I don't know ok
and then obviously black resigned
showing he wasn't the real Savchenko
right he's like the fake one yeah yeah
sort of like vine gold come on
terrible yeah and the senator Feingold
the guy's got to retire oh he did ok
terrible all right least but not last
he played Arenberg again except this
time he was Wyatt ok this is in a rapid
game now I have a rule which epochal
applies to this position ok all Rick and
pawn endings are winning the the normal
rule which I don't abide by is they're
all drawn but when I look at the game
they're all winning so now this is
actually drawn that's okay because white
one yeah White's better here obviously
frankly and he made a bad move and now
white played h4 put it in H okay and
black maids of losing move normally in
end games when you're down upon or down
to pawns or in Julian's case down three
pawns and Mario's case down eight pawns
when you're down a lot of pawns you want
to trade all the pawns your opponent has
one pawn left and they can't win okay
this is the exception that proves the
rule that's good
this endgame we need lots of puns on the
board so that black can attack lots of
pawns
black needs to take those pawns if we
don't take those pawns White's going to
win well black ledum move where he was a
hundred percent sure not to take any
pawns okay so he just lost out of hand
with no with no problem okay
according to the engine rook F to check
gives excellent drawing chances the idea
is if you move back that's very nice
that was good progress you made you move
back you can't do anything and if you
try to make progress with King e4 to
escort your pawn home with your king
these pawns are always drunk okay here
and the King is helping now we play rook
h2 gimmi gimmi gimmi and black has good
counter play he might try to win all of
whites pawns black has good chances to
draw okay instead of doing that he
played g5 check the losing move exactly
and now after a trade white runs his
King over and his rook can easily defend
the g4 pawn okay if you play rook g2 I
play rookie for now as we've discussed
in every endgame lecture I've ever given
this is terrible you can't have a bad
King in the endgame this King is going
to escort our pawn to a queen this King
isn't doing anything if you want to draw
this position you play king h4 if your
opponent's not looking play King h5 see
what happens now they say it's illegal
make another move okay
I'm not advocating cheating but you know
you got to do something
all right so that King is terrible
White's King is gray black doesn't have
counterplay because there's no pawns to
attack okay so King g6 King d5 King f6
King c5 now we're ready
the king is protecting everything this
King can't go anywhere although I would
still try of course well I play King f5
because King e5 that's that's going too
far
okay so rook C to check king b5 work
there now he wants to play rook f4 and
attack that pawn white was very scared
of that and he wasn't scared at all okay
yeah he defended his pawn that was about
it now forcing the white rook to g3 is
good because now the white rook isn't
cutting off the black King so blacks
King you know can come alright now we're
going to vote and see what you guys
learned about the endgame today we got
to move our King
so our pawn can go forward that's a good
idea right and the King has lots of
squares to go to even this illegal one I
can still highlight it okay so of the
six highlighted squares which is the
best move for the King somebody who's
not Julian kokumo King c5 because he
does two things
he gets his king out of the way so the
pawn can shoot up and he stops blacks
King from defending King c5 black can't
come over and stop the pawn yeah
what's king c5 called opposition yeah
I'm kidding
shouldering up the king I mean I could
do that right who's the King now see
George now isn't there Queen what who
yeah leave the king in a while have we
time to react to King why don't I call
the Atlanta Hawks and see if they can
shoulder out the King no nobody are they
still going to be in it when this video
is shown or will the Cavs have slept
them by then oh yeah they can't they
can't sweep them in freed three days
they can't do it okay no I was just
teasing few Hawks fans at home
you're going to win a game for four
games to one yeah now that's the one
thing I said before having that's going
to be right okay so now all those great
Atlanta players will do well now I can't
think of any okay so Rick f1 black is
going to put White's king in check
unless White has something to say about
it and white played I gave you the
answer yeah remember I gave you the
answer I mean b5 is okay but better is
much better is so what's that Brooks III
Black has two threads blacks threading
the check and my comer wouldn't put up
with that or king F for counter play so
we play rooks III we stop the checks and
we stop the counter play because the
rook on c4 is going to defend the pawn
rugby one a useless move check and if
you checks again where would the white
king move trick question it's a trick
question
where was the white king move where move
the king up takes those own pond yeah
exactly
I assume you mean Rick c4 yeah okay yeah
I thought king takes my alright so he
played rugby 1 b6 King d5 b7 and that
pawn is getting it's getting rough over
here right okay now since Rick b1 check
does nothing because of rugby 3 man
blacks defense wasn't too good this kid
so it's funny black went from probably a
drawing position to dead dead dead loss
by playing g5 check because he had no
white pawns to capture because he traded
them off that's unusual usually trade
all the pawns off you're good but here
we never win the pawn on g4 we don't
stop the pawn from queening and black
did his usual resigns
yeah and that's two games that ehrenberg
lost to Harry Krishna I can't believe it
terrible game now for a trivia at the
end of the class okay and then is this
going to sound like a joke but I'm right
what is Harry Krishna's favorite food
the correct answer is you obviously knew
was okra okra is Hari Krishna's favorite
food he's the only person in the world
whose favorite food is okra that's would
be somebody right so it's him yeah and I
think he's a vegetarian if he's not then
you are now so you know what I'm talking
about okay now he's a nice guy too I'm
glad I did a lecture on him because
usually it's like a non who's the second
best player in India Anand who's the
third best Anand so we got to like
talking about some of the other guys
you